today on the matt walsh show as climate
change alarmists become more frantic
about our alleged impending doom they
have also started to sound more and more
genocidal we'll discuss plus the left
now claims that abortion bans are a
racist conspiracy to ensure that more
white babies are born of course this
claim completely contradicts all the
facts and tucker carlson is criticized
for urging young people to get married
and have kids if you can imagine what a
terrible thing in our daily cancellation
a tragic story of sexism and patriarchy
it'll be hard to talk about but we must
all of that and much more today on the
matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well if you haven't looked over your
budget in a while now may be a good time
see what your biggest expenses are where
you can cut back and find ways to make
an impact and now is now is definitely
the time to do that if you're a
homeowner your equity is up 20 and it
can be accessed as cash for everything
that you need uh you all you got to do
if you want to access it is call
american financing you can get a free
mortgage review and let them look at
your entire financial picture it's so
easy on your end all you got to do is
just give them a call from your home
loan to your equity even your high
interest debt they'll uh review all of
it and they'll do everything they can to
help you save up to a thousand dollars a
month think of the difference that can
make we're all looking for ways to save
uh these days and this is one way you
can do it if you're even if your credit
isn't great just give them a call and
see what they can do i'm sure they can
help you it only takes 10 minutes when
you call and what you have to call is
the number
866-569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net and
334 and mls consumeraccess.org
when i went to africa visiting the
maasai tribe for my film what is a woman
i of course discovered that gender
theory simply doesn't exist in that part
of the world at all we had so much to
talk about around that subject that i
didn't have time to ask them about other
western liberal inventions which is
probably for the best because they
already thought that i was insane enough
as it was
but i imagine that if i'd continued down
the left-wing checklist we would have
gotten the same guffaws and confused
head scratching and looks of pity
and this includes especially includes
actually the subject of environmentalism
i'm pretty certain that if i'd ask the
maasai how they feel about the
environment and whether they identify as
environmentalists
the question would have made as much
sense as asking them whether men can
have babies and this would hold true all
across the non-western world
like gender theory environmentalism is a
modern liberal western
luxury belief system
and one that we've been hearing about
more and more in recent weeks as the
left rediscovers the insidious
phenomenon known as summer that's not to
say that that people in non-western
regions don't respect nature or try to
preserve its beauty and character i mean
the messiah live much closer to nature
are much much more in tune with it
dependent on it absorbed in it and by it
than the college-educated liberal who
opines about the beauty of nature from
the comfort of his urban apartment whose
window provides a view of concrete and
steel and glass and nothing that could
be called natural at all
he loves nature yet lives as far from it
as he can get he takes pride
in his quote unquote green lifestyle but
the only green he sees is a few tufts of
grass on a median strip
you also may encounter the green hues of
a mountain dew billboard or
of the various suspicious liquids on the
sidewalk of unknown and unspeakable
origins
he doesn't love nature more than the
people who actually live in it but he
has made an ism of it
and it's the ism that is unique and
would be incoherent to most people in
most parts of the world
in fact the ism environmentalism is
incoherent to most people in this part
of the world too i mean folks living out
in the country have have heard of
environmentalism but none of them
identify with it or buy it
go out to the country godzilla rural
area and ask them any environmentalists
here you're going to get just blank
stares
environmentalism is an ideology for
people who are the most far removed and
shielded from the environment
and can therefore afford to fetishize it
it's an ideology for people like
george monbio he's an author and an
award-winning journalist who has in
recent years been on a crusade to save
the environment by pushing for the
abolition of farming he appeared on a
news show in ireland last week to
deliver his standard indictment of the
practice let's listen to that
it's by far and away the greatest cause
of habitat destruction the greatest
cause of wildlife loss the greatest
cause of extinction greatest cause of
soil loss greatest source of fresh water
use it's one of the greatest causes of
climate breakdown um bigger than
transport um one of the primary causes
of water pollution and of air pollution
so it's right at the top oh and sorry i
forgot to say land use the biggest issue
of all it's by far and away the greatest
form of land use that humans
inflict on the planet which means all
that land is land which can't be used
for wild ecosystems
and while obviously we need farming we
need to minimize those impacts we we
need um to act as drastically within
that sector as any other sector to
prevent the collapse of our life support
systems and what that means above all
else is getting out of livestock farming
is really shutting down animal farming
altogether because that has massively
disproportionate impacts on the living
planet and we need to switch towards
other sources of food plant-based diets
which are far more efficient far lower
environmental impacts but also switch
out of farming all together to produce
protein-rich foods which we can do
through precision fermentation george
microbes i can hear farmers all over the
small country of ours shocked and
perhaps screaming at their television
because they're saying are you saying
all animal farming in in your opinion
really needs to stop
yes it does it really does um it's a bit
like leaving fossil fuels in the ground
unless we do that we've really got very
little chance indeed of
preventing this domino effect of system
collapse right across earth systems
which basically makes the planet
uninhabitable so eating meat and milk
and eggs is an indulgence we cannot
afford
now we know that george is an anti-human
psychopath based on the fact that as we
see in the video there he hangs his
picture frames from wires suspended from
the ceiling his home decor is exactly
the sort of thing that you see right
before you're skinned alive and
dismembered of course for liability
and legal reasons i am not directly
alleging that george is a serial killer
i'm just saying that i would be
surprised if he wasn't
and whether he personally murders people
or not we do know that he subscribes to
a murderous ideology climate alarmists
like george are anti-human
anti-civilization
they see all of humanity well most of it
anyway with the exception of themselves
as a blight a stain a parasite on the
face of the earth just listen to his
word choice this is what these people
always say they always say stuff like
this he says that farming is the worst
form of land use that humans inflict on
the planet and that we're hogging land
which could be better used by flowers
and bees and caterpillars and other
non-sentient life forms
environmentalism is it is not an
exaggeration to say a genocidal ideology
that's always been the case but usually
they're not as open about it as george
is in this clip
he obviously knows that we can't produce
cricket energy bars and tofu burgers
quickly enough and distribute them
widely enough to feed everybody
he says that livestock farming eating
eggs and drinking milk is a mere
indulgence that the planet can't afford
to support any longer yet billions of
people in the world depend on livestock
livestock farming to survive especially
in poor countries the messiah subsists
almost entirely on goats and cows
take those away and they'll all starve
to death
billions of people will starve along
with them
environmentalists know this and they're
just okay with it more than okay it's
what they want
mass starvation is as they say a feature
not a bug
you really can't be anti-farming without
being anti-civilization human
civilization is based on agriculture it
was born from and by agriculture it was
only after the development of
agriculture that civilizations formed in
the first place the neolithic revolution
saw humanity move away from primitive
nomadic hunter-gatherer society
societies that could not really thrive
or grow in any kind of wide scale to the
cultivation of plants and animals and
the forming of organized permanent
settlements it's not exaggeration to say
that that people like george
literally want to bring us back to the
stone age they want to reverse the clock
by about 10 000 years give or take
now such a move would be disastrous for
all the billions of poor people who
would immediately perish but would also
be a disaster for urban
environmentalists who lie whose lives
depend entirely on the very farmers they
abhor
that's the other thing about climate
alarmists they
these people they don't have the skills
to survive in the world they're trying
to create
they have no skills at all most of them
that's why so few of the climate change
chicken littles have put their money
where their mouths are and forsaken
modern technology to go live in
self-sustaining communes in the woods a
few of them have very few
the vast majority of them have not
sacrificed even one ounce of modern
luxury or convenience
they profess that an environmental
apocalypse is upon us the the exact
details change three times a week of
course but there's always an apocalypse
that they maintain and yet they continue
to live exactly as they've always lived
exactly as the rest of us live
exactly as they insist we should not be
living
they haven't even relocated the higher
ground for fear that the sea will soon
engulf them
in fact many of them specifically
congregate right near the coastlines
why is that
you know if i were in their boat and
believed what they claimed to believe
first i would actually well i would
actually build a boat probably and i
would do many other things i would i
would feel morally obligated to take
extreme measures as a member of the
enlightened few as a person who knows
that human life is about to be
eradicated
and who knows why and even when
i would feel an incredible burden of
responsibility if i knew that driving my
car
turning on my light shopping at the mall
and generally going about my day
immersed in modern luxury were all
directly causing the current and future
deaths of millions of people i couldn't
continue engaging in those legal lethal
activities at all
i would see it as an act of extreme
moral recklessness if not murder
to saunter along as usual
my conscience would compel me to ensure
that i am not responsible personally for
the carnage that is about to occur and
is already occurring they tell us
i mean they say that when you when you
use your car or
when you do any of these modern things
you're actually you're creating like
hurricanes and tornadoes you are doing
that
well if i believe that i just i could
never get in a car ever again
i can never use electricity ever again
how could a person who believes what
they allegedly believe possibly arrive
at any other conclusion
and yet they do continue along like
everything is fine
i mean they say otherwise
they say that things are not fine that's
not how they live
is that because they don't actually
believe most of this stuff that's what i
suspect speaking of which al gore
appeared on meet the press on sunday to
say that
people who don't join him in his
panicking over the climate
are just like the police officers in
uvalde listen to this
you know the climate deniers
are
really in some ways similar to all of
those almost 400 law enforcement
officers in uvalde texas
who were waiting outside an unlocked
door
while the
children were being mastered they heard
the screams they heard the gunshots and
nobody has stepped forward and god bless
those families who've suffered so much
and law enforcement officials told us
that's not typical of what
law enforcement usually does
and
confronted with this global emergency
what we're doing with our inaction and
failing to walk through the door and
stop the killing
is not typical of what we are capable of
as human beings
we do have the solutions and i think
these extreme events that are getting
steadily worse and more severe are
really beginning to change minds we have
to have uh unity as a nation to come
together and stop making this a
political football it shouldn't be a
partisan issue
i feel the need to always
remind everyone every time i hear this
phrase climate deniers that there's
there's no such thing as a climate
denier nobody denies that we live in a
climate no one is denying the climate
exists no one's even died that the
climate is changing because climates
always change no one's dying any of that
what some of us are denying is the
apocalyptic
forecast that people like
al gore are
telling us about and we have good reason
to deny it because they've given us many
of these forecasts and they've all
turned out to be wrong every single one
anyway at least al gore doesn't look as
much like a serial killer as the other
guy though he does physically resemble
more and more like a villain from a
saturday morning cartoon he looks like
something that someone actually drew it
doesn't look like a person
and here he shames us in the strongest
term saying that if you're not losing
your mind over our alleged impending
environmental doom you're a you're
morally analogous to a person who cowers
outside of a classroom
while children are shot
these are strident words of course for a
guy who lives in a 10 000 square foot
mansion that uses 20 times more
electricity than average
but gore's hypocrisy is so well known
that it's almost a cliche
the hypocrisy of environmentalists in
general is widely understood and
discussed
yet the fact that these people don't
seem to actually believe what they're
saying remains extremely relevant i
think
and can't be pointed out enough
and even if i'm wrong even if they do
believe this stuff
the fact is that they're still in a bind
of their own making they militate
against modern society and its luxuries
but they're utterly dependent on it
their ideology puts them at war with
their own lifestyles a lifestyle of
helpless dependence
so when they come out against
electricity and fossil fuels and farming
and all the rest
they are sawing at the branch that
they're sitting on
cutting and cutting away but in the back
of their minds
hoping desperately they never cut all
the way through
because that's a long plunge to the
forest floor
some of us may survive the fall but they
surely
will not
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well the latest inflation numbers are in
and uh it's not looking good we've hit a
40-year high at 9.1 percent thanks to
this genius administration that we have
our nation's authorities are now openly
admitting to having completely missed
the flashing red lights of inflation and
this administration's failed economic
policy treasury secretary janet yellen
admitted that she was wrong about the
path inflation would take saying quote
there have been unanticipated and large
shocks of the economy that have boosted
energy and food prices and supply
bottlenecks that have affected our
economy badly but at the time i didn't
fully understand well there you have it
now i know you're worried about
affording basic necessities in the
months to come food gas shelter all the
rest of it but uh she didn't know it's
not her fault cut her some slack
well cause that's saying that uh you
can't trust the so-called authorities on
economic policy which is why you should
invest at least some of your money in
gold and silver with birch gold protect
your savings from a highly turbulent
economy by diversifying your 401k or ira
into physical gold it's not too late for
you now to take action text walsh to
98989 and get a free info kit on
diversifying and protecting your savings
with precious metals birch gold group
has an a plus rating with the best
better business bureau countless five
star reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers text walsh to 989898 and get
real advice from birch gold today again
text walsh to 989898
to claim your free no obligation info
kit on protecting your savings with gold
all right it's good to be uh
back in nashville finally back in front
of the trusty old sheet here uh made the
thousand-mile drive back over a thousand
miles actually four kids
though for the second half of the drive
home we we only had one kid we dropped
the older three off with my parents for
to spend the week there spend you know a
week with nana and grandpa my youngest
daughter is two years old not old enough
to be away that long so
we're in the the weird position this
week um
alyssa and i of of um having one kid and
we've never had one kid before because
we
we started off with two right off the
bat so we never experienced this
and i will admit
that
for the first day we were pretty cocky
about it
and and we did amongst ourselves say
some kind of judgmental things
about parents who have just one kid and
complain about how overwhelming it is
and how hard it is
because we have one kid we're like what
are we even supposed to do this is so
easy
we have two of us and one kid
but it was as if our two-year-old was
listening to this and decided to to
humble us and punish us
righteously for our arrogance because uh
she decided to take this week as an
opportunity to stop sleeping
and maybe it's just that she looked
around and realized that she's alone so
she needs to pick up the slack and be
sort of irritating enough to compensate
for the fact that her siblings aren't
around i don't know what it is but last
night she wouldn't sleep
she was up repeatedly
crying and i went into her room and she
was saying that she was too scared to
sleep and i said there's nothing to be
scared of
and then she told me that she heard a
baby crying outside in the woods and a
man laughing in her closet
and i thought wow that is pretty scary
actually now i can't sleep
and she asked me to go out into the
woods and investigate the sound
and i said i'm not doing it you go out
there i'm not going out there you
kidding me i've seen enough horror
movies to know what happens if you're
the guy who goes out into the woods to
investigate the sound so anyway we
brought her down and brought her down
into our bed she slept in our bed and uh
she was splayed out because this is how
kids kids sleep like like they're in a
synchronized swimming routine and she's
just moving all over the place splayed
out horizontally across the bed kicking
me in the chin all night long
and i know i'm in trouble now because
there's nothing this is one thing
parents know that if you take if you if
you let your toddler sleep in your bed
it's like leaving food out for a stray
cat they're they're never gonna go away
now you're stuck with them there so
we're gonna have her as a roommate until
she's like eight years old
but we are getting what we deserve i
guess for our as i said our arrogance
um
i've been a parent long enough i should
know that never you never say this you
know oh this is easy never say that
you're just asking for it so we'll start
with this for the past several weeks um
and long before that we've been
repeatedly told that banning abortion is
especially an attack on racial
minorities right we've heard this many
times
black women suffer the most from not
being able to kill their children we're
told
but this line of attack i guess proved
not very effective and it just it just
sounds it sounds wrong doesn't it to say
that
so it seems like the left has abandoned
it for now
and gone all the way to the other
extreme
so this is what they do of course if one
narrative doesn't work just try the
exact opposite of that narrative doesn't
matter doesn't matter if what you're
saying from one sentence to the next is
coherent or or makes sense so alexandria
samuels is a reporter for 538
and she tweeted this uh yesterday she
said the fight over abortion rights is
tied to the great replacement theory and
fears that white people will become a
minority
that fear never left the anti-abortion
movement which at its core has always
been about upholding white supremacy
and she links to an article in 538
authored by herself and someone named
monica potts titled how the fight to ban
abortion is rooted in the great
replacement theory
so here's how it begins it says
it may not be immediately obvious how
the fight over abortion rights is tied
to the great replacement theory the
debunked conspiracy theory promoted by
some republican politicians who claim
that democrats support more immigration
to replace white american voters
the explanation for say an alleged gaffe
that overturning the constitutional
right to an abortion is a historic
victory of white life quote unquote or a
concern that not enough white babies are
being born in the u.s can be found in
the history of the anti-abortion
movement the movement and legal abortion
has a long racist history and like the
great replacement theory it has roots in
a similar fear that white people are
going to be outnumbered by people
believed to hold a lower standing in
society those anxieties used to be
centered primarily around various groups
of european immigrants and newly
emancipated slaves but now they're
focused on non-white americans who as a
group are on track to numerically
outpace non-hispanic white americans by
2045.
um etc and so forth
the anti-abortion movement at its core
has always been about upholding white
supremacy right
now we have to of course stipulate at
the outset once again that
the so-called great replacement theory
is not a theory
and it's not something that the right
invented it's something that the left
came up with
and it's it's a thing that they're
actually doing and that they've been
very open about
they are importing voters from other
countries this is not this is
very clearly what they're doing uh it is
not a conspiracy theory it's not a guess
it's not an opinion it's just what
they're doing
and they've often admitted it
you could just quote them directly
talking about this
but that aside
um
you see how this narrative completely
contradicts
the one they were going with up until
five seconds ago
before it was well it's wrong to ban
abortion because uh black women
you know in particular quote unquote
need abortions
and now it's uh it's wrong
to ban it because this is all this this
is a conspiracy to
increase the percentage of white people
in the population
well this doesn't make any sense at all
here's the figure that matters
black women are seven percent of the
population give or take
the black population as a whole is about
13 so women we figured probably seven
seven percent or so
and they account for i think it's about
34 of abortions
so well over four times
their population percentage
and what that means is that um
when you ban abortion
you are going to increase the black
population as a percentage of the
overall hull a whole
much more than you're going to increase
the white population
as a percentage of the overall hole
that's just the fact of the matter
so
uh
you you could try to say whatever you
want about pro-lifers
but the claim that's
in whichever angle you're coming from
the claim that pro-lifers are racist and
that the the push to ban abortion is a
racist conspiracy it just doesn't make
any sense
given that every pro-lifer knows that
you get rid of abortion
and that means that you're going to end
up with more minorities not less as a
percentage
in fact that's not just something that
we're like aware of
that's something that we often talk
about
and observe how planned parenthood
uh was was born in you know as as a
in eugenics i mean margaret sanger the
founder of plant parenthood was a
eugenicist
and she believed in using abortion to
get rid of
what she considered to be the dregs of
society
she was very open about that in fact the
the early advocates of abortion
were all very open about their
eugenicist leanings
they consider this to be one of the one
of the great selling points of abortion
they've talked about it all the time
so this is something that it's it's uh
this is something pro-lifers very often
bring up
get rid of abortion and uh
racial minorities will end up being less
of a minority than they are now
and you can look at the figures on this
and it's it's hard to estimate exactly
but
how many fewer black people are in the
country today
because of abortion
i don't know the exact number off top of
my head and like i said it's a it's it's
a difficult thing to you know there's
not an exact figure you can arrive at
but it's certainly millions
if not for abortion there would be
millions more black people in the
country today than there currently
so banning abortion is racist right
makes a lot of sense
all right moving on to this dr fauci is
uh calling on americans to he's humming
his uh same old tune calling on
americans to put masks on again let's
listen to that
you are in a zone or a or a or a county
state or a city that has a very high
level of dynamic of viral circulation
the cdc would recommend strongly
that you wear a mask in a congregate
indoor setting
and that would include schools places of
work
anything that brings people together in
a closed
environment
that is good
public health practice
um i'll i'll give you a no on that one
not gonna happen at all
but as we as we hear this this push to
get us back in masks again and and fauci
he's just he's of course never gonna let
go of this because this is
this is uh his last
you know shot at relevance and power and
he's had more relevance and more power
because of cover than he ever enjoyed at
any other point in his life
and that's obviously why he's been in
government for so long
that's why almost everybody is in
government because they want they want
they want power they want control it's
why you get into that line of work in
the first place and um
and so he can't let go of it you know
this is this is how he defines himself
but as this push as we get this
once again this push for for masking
uh we're going to hear more and more
about so-called
long covid
and it seems like every month there's
another study that discovers more quote
unquote symptoms of long covid and so
here's the latest
this is from uh
an article in study fines it says hair
loss and a low sex drive
are joining the growing list of
lingering symptoms people are dealing
with after a case of coven 19 a
condition called long covid the major
british study involved more than 2
million people and adds these problems
to a list that already includes brain
fog and chronic fatigue now researchers
have discovered that long covet
sufferers have experienced a much wider
set of over 60 symptoms including sexual
dysfunction and alopecia
uh previous studies have found that the
list could actually be closer to 200
symptoms
the fascinating thing about long coveted
symptoms is that
well a couple of things
many of them are these kind of ambiguous
subjective
brain fog chronic fatigue like i'm just
feeling tired i'm feeling foggy it's
hard to even
describe that exactly quantify it
they're the kind of symptoms that pretty
much anyone can be convinced they have
you could convince
anyone in the country that they have
brain fog and chronic fatigue
and actually that is that that's that's
just a that's that's a symptom of living
in modern society
where you're
you're
constantly staring at screens all the
time makes your brain foggy uh almost
nobody is getting the amount of sleep
they should be getting that can be
traced back to the screens
so
these long covet symptoms often are
things like that
and there's also things that that happen
to people anyway like brain fog and
fatigue but you know hair loss
um
all these things are just normal
especially as you get older
so remember this
anything that happens
after covid is long covered like
anything that happens to you
any symptom that you suffer from after
you have code is long covered
that's basically i mean 200 symptoms so
that's really just anything at all any
sensation any physical event anything at
all that happens to you after you have
coveted is long coveted but
nothing that happens after you get the
vaccine
is a side effect of the vaccine
so that's the way that this worked this
is science folks okay
literally everything that happens after
covet is long covered literally nothing
that happens after the vaccine is a side
effect of the vaccine
good science here's some more good
science and this i think is um a very
interesting art article especially
considering what we talked about last
week with the uh the study on
antidepressants and how antidepressants
have been prescribed to millions of
people for decades based on a myth the
myth of the chemical imbalance that
causes depression
well something similar seems to
potentially be happening with
alzheimer's this is from
nbc it says allegations
that part of a key 2006 study of
alzheimer's disease may have been
fabricated have rocked the research
community calling into question the
validity of the study's influential
results science magazine said thursday
that it uncovered evidence that images
in the much cited study published 16
years ago in the journal nature
may have been doctored
the findings have thrown skepticism on
the work of
sylvain lesni who's a neuroscientist and
associate professor at the university of
minnesota in his research which fueled
interest in a specific assembly of
proteins as a promising target for
treatment of alzheimer's disease
lesney didn't respond to nbc news's
request for comment nor did he provide
comments to science magazine science
said that it found more than 20 suspect
papers
by this guy and identified more than 70
instances of possible image tampering in
his studies
a whistleblower dr matthew schrag who is
a neuroscientist at vanderbilt
university raised concern last year
about the possible manipulation of
images in multiple papers
carl hurup who's a professor of
neurobiology at the university of
pittsburgh brain institute who was an
involved investigation said the findings
are really bad for science uh he said
it's never shameful to be wrong in
science a lot of the best science was
done by people being wrong and proving
it
if they were wrong and then why they're
wrong what is completely toxic is to be
fraudulent
now
what makes this so bad is that
this is they're saying this was an
influential study which probably
understates
you know the case quite a bit because
people were being treated
for alzheimer's based on this study that
was done
and according to this
new research again it's not just that
they were wrong about it it's that the
the results were falsified
so this is a an enormous scandal
that calls for congressional hearings
investigations trials people should be
going to prison for this
and we have to know is it was it just
this one guy who falsified the findings
and nobody else knew about it
that seems kind of hard to believe
we're talking about over 15 years with
uh with you know alzheimer's being
treated according to this study and
there was that
apparently the results in the study were
falsified and no nobody else knew
or even suspected except for this one
guy who did it
um that's really hard to believe
so there need to be hearings there need
to be i mean this is a this is a major
scandal that comes on the heels it's
like this was a two days after the
anti-depressant scandal which was also a
major scandal
that were that's that that we're talking
about billions of dollars caught up in
into this
fraudulently
it implicates the pharmaceutical
industry doctors i mean everybody's
caught up in this web
and if we're taking it seriously then we
need investigations into this to find
out who exactly is responsible what
happened people need to pay the price
but here's but here's the really
helpless thing that we all know that
nothing will happen
when it comes to either of these
especially with the antidepressant
thing but but even with this as well my
prediction is nothing happens at all
nobody is held accountable
they'll talk about doing investigations
they'll maybe they will have a couple of
hearings who knows
but nothing will happen
i mean the uh the corruption in the
pharmaceutical industry it would be
impossible to overstate
and as we talked about yesterday
one of the reasons why there is very
little accountability
is because there aren't as many people
in the country calling for it
you know if the public pressure built
enough then there would have to be
some kind of accountability to assuage
all the outrage
but i think for a lot of people you know
they are dependent on the pharmaceutical
industry
uh we we live in at a country of full of
uh drug addicts
even though many of them are dependent
on legal drugs that are prescribed to
them and they go to rite aid to pick
them up but they're drug addicts
and so i think they just they don't
really want to know the truth
so we're all kind of whistling past the
graveyard with all this stuff
all right this is a an article from the
guardian
that i wanted to mention this is a
written by a guy named sebastian cohn
talking about his experiences with
monkey pox
and he says
i got monkey pox and it's been a total
nightmare i only need to read like the
first paragraph or two of this
so you get the idea
when new york pride festivities kicked
off on the 24th of june i was aware that
monkey pox was an emerging issue
especially for gay men
but i was also under the impression that
the number of cases in the city was
relatively small what i didn't
understand how apps was how absolutely
dismal testing capacity was at that
point the city only had capacity to
process 10 tests a day
then he says i had sex with several guys
over the weekend then a week later on
the first of july i started feeling
fatigued i had a high fever with chills
and muscle aches and my lymph nodes were
so swollen that they were protruding two
inches out of my throat first i took a
covet self test it was negative then i
started suspecting monkey box i texted a
friend i'm just sitting here waiting for
the rash to start
uh and then it get we go into
a lot of details you probably don't need
about the the rash and that broke out
all over
his body in particular in certain parts
of his body that you know you can
imagine we don't need to describe them
and um
and he had and it turns out that he had
monkey box and it was a it was a
terrible ordeal which i can imagine
based on the description that it was
but who does he blame
you know he doesn't blame
himself certainly he blames the city he
blames
who anybody else the testing capacity
and yet he says right at the start of
the article
that uh
he had sex with several guys over the
weekend just kind of a toss-off sentence
like it's nothing
oh yeah well text with several guys
that's how i celebrate
pride well here's the thing
even if monkey pox didn't exist
which it did and you admit at the outset
that you knew that it was out there
you knew that it was that it was flaring
up in new york and yeah you still would
have had sex with several guys but even
if there was no monkey pox
that kind of behavior is reckless
and dangerous regardless
because of all the other diseases that
you can get
um and this kind of behavior
is why
the gay community is far more
susceptible to any range of diseases
it's not just monkey pox or hiv though
it is those
many other stds as well
and yet so kind of on the theme here of
the uh
the
medical industry
you know fraud fraudulent behavior in
the medical industry up on the part of
the medical industry and the public
so-called public health experts
this is as as much as they lectured us
during covid for
like going to the grocery store
uh not wearing a mask you know even if
you're at well if you gather even in
your own home with your friends and
family who don't live in your home you
don't put a mask on but you get lectured
for that
what did they say they still say it you
don't put a mask on your uh so you're
not just hurting yourself you're killing
right you're killing everyone's you're
uh you're
killing everyone's grandparents
and yet nobody wants to say to people
like sebastian cohn
you know what it is incredibly reckless
and wrong
to go out and just have sex with random
people
no matter what diseases are circulating
because they're always going to be
whether it's monkey pox or any of the
other dozens of diseases that you can
contract
and also spread
that is a lifestyle choice that nobody
should be engaging in ever
you know the thing is it should be a lot
easier to stop doing that
than it was for
the rest of society to stop living their
everyday normal lives for two years
all right moving to this this is from
the independent
says tucker carlson has some unique
advice for his young male fans drop out
of college and have more children than
you can afford
the popular but controversial fox news
host himself a bow tie wearing product
of boarding schools debate societies and
a liberal arts college made the comments
on sunday during the interview carlson
and host daniel schmidt a student at the
university of chicago bonded over what
the youtube host called a pervasive
amount of anti-white sentiment okay so
this is just a hit piece bouncing all
over the place uh that doesn't matter
what does matter is this clip which has
made the rounds online and there are
people that are upset about it as well
because carlson said it which means
people are upset about it but let's
listen to the advice that he gives go
ahead
achievement comes through commitment and
responsibility so my advice to young
people particularly young men
is just dive face-first into it like
drop out of college college is
ridiculous unless you're moving towards
some very specialized degree that you
can only get in college if you want to
be a veterinarian or a physicist or
something but if you're in humanities
you know i can give you a list of 100
books you can find it on the internet
and you'll be better educated than you
would be at whatever stupid college you
go to a b
get married
and you know
choose wisely but don't overthink it
you know don't overthink it people
overthink it like if you're compatible
with someone
and you can smell that
you can make it work and by the way it's
never easy because men and women
fundamentally don't understand each
other that's the whole joy in it that's
why marriage makes you grow
is because you don't really understand
the other person so you have to try
every day
to decipher what that person's saying
have more children than you can afford
take a job you're not qualified for
like go balls out
you just go balls out i don't know what
is everyone waiting for you know have
some adventure in your life do something
crazy i mean it and and i don't mean you
know go to bali skip bali please
uh well of course people are upset about
the what he says there the insight he
provides because it's true right and if
you provide true insight into life
you're always going to upset people
these days
he touches on a couple of things there
that are really important one one the
one that he says you know don't
overthink it when it comes to marriage
and this is something this is a drum
that i've been beating for years
um and he's exactly right about that
and if you listen to people who are
actually married and have been married
successfully and are in happy marriages
you're all this is this is this is you
know there's wide agreement among
actually married people
um it's only people that aren't married
that are scandalized by this kind of
thing that should tell you something
because it doesn't mean that you know
you meet someone
and you kind of like them so you get
married the next day okay no one's
saying that we'll run off to las vegas
and get married in a drive-through
wedding after one day no one is saying
that but if you if you beat them
and uh you like them and you're
attracted to them
and you're compatible
and also you you note that you have
you know your your fundamental values
align
which is something that you can discover
about someone early on by actually like
talking to them
if you have real conversations with them
rather than inane small talk all the
time you can discover all of that very
quickly
and um
and then at that point like what what
else is there to wait for what are you
waiting around i mean you can see these
days people think well
okay i'm attracted to them i like them
we get along we're compatible
we have our fundamental values do align
uh but uh we we need to date for 17
years you know and we got to move in
together and because we're going to have
to know every last detail about this
person what if they have what if there
are things about them that annoy me
right i got to find that out first
no you don't need to find it out because
i'll tell you the answer right now there
are there are a ton of things that annoy
you about that because they're a per
they're another person they're a whole
other human being and so they're you're
not going to be compatibility is not
going to be 100
there are going to be difficulties
you're going to be bumping up against
each other on various different topics
all the time that's just part of living
with someone you work through that
that's part of marriage
and the thing is it doesn't even matter
like
you can spend years with someone getting
to know every last detail about them
and uh and then you say okay we're ready
to get married and you get married well
you still gotta start
right eventually you're gonna have your
first day of marriage
it doesn't matter how much time you
spent with them ahead of time
once you get married you're you're
married now the game changes you're a
rookie i don't care if you knew that
person for 15 years ahead of time
you're basically in the same boat as
someone who
knew their spouse for
15 minutes because now you're starting
at square one you've got to start in
square one
and you have your first day of marriage
together and then your next the next day
and the day after that
and you got to put the work in every
single day
it doesn't matter how good things seem
heading into it if you're not willing to
put the work in every day then it's not
going to work out
and then the other thing that he says
that i that is a is a
another really important point that i'm
always trying to stress
is this idea of like having a sense of
adventure and i think that this was
advice directed particularly at men
it applies to women too but but i think
especially to men
having a sense of
adventure and that's the point about the
makes about you know have more kids than
you can afford take a job you aren't
qualified for
the point is um it's not to be reckless
it's just to stop calibrating and
triangulating and stalling all the time
which is what so many young people young
men especially that they waste
adulthood young adulthood stalling you
know just waiting around
for a sign from heaven that now you can
move forward and actually live your life
at a certain point you got to jump in
and take some risks
yeah have a sense of adventure
which means like move out of the house
go do something
frustrates me to no end when i hear
these young guys
uh complaining even about you know well
there's no there's no jobs there's no
opportunities around where i live
or there there are no people you know
there's no women there's no good women
around where i live which there probably
are but you know you haven't looked hard
enough or you're looking in the wrong
places but whatever okay even if that's
true then move somewhere else
you're a young single guy if you're a
young single able-bodied guy
you have no dependence
you have no serious responsibilities in
life
now there could be some complicating
situations for some people maybe of an
ailing parent that you can't move away
from okay if that's the case for you
then that's different but if that's not
the case if you don't have anyone
dependent on you
and you're young and single and a man
and you're body then you can go anywhere
and try anything
just move go somewhere if it doesn't
work out go somewhere else
worst case scenario you get someone i
can't find a job i'll be okay so you're
living out of your car for a few weeks
whatever you're fine you'll survive
that's that's the adventure that's the
kind of thing that you know you do
things like that and you take risks
and then uh later on in life you those
are the kind of stories you tell your
kids and your grandkids
but i think for a lot of people they're
never going to have any stories because
like they spent their 20s what are you
going to tell your grandkids about
all the time you spend in your mom's
house playing video games
you're not gonna have any grandkids
anyway
so i think that's a great great moment
there from
tucker carlson and that's a great time
to get to our comment
know their section
they're the sweet baby gang
[Music]
all right let's see
uh message from kyle says matt why is
your show so inconsistent lately another
day off on monday what's going on
well i'm sorry kyle went on vacation at
the beginning of july
then over the weekend like i said we
drove over a thousand miles okay so i
had to miss a day for that is that is
that okay i mean cut me some slack man
my you know here's the thing and i've
gotten a lot of messages from people
like this especially after taking the
day off on monday people very upset at
me
my workaholic brain already makes me
feel guilty for taking any time off at
all and then i get messages from people
that are mad at me for it it just does
it doesn't help okay
you guys are really encouraging some
unhealthy behaviors
on the other hand i understand that
running a cult you know running the sbg
cult is a responsibility and there are
expectations that come with that so i
understand that as well
um
austin fan for life says i would love to
see matt in charge of hr just to see
someone explain a pronoun change just
for matt to end the meeting with you
don't get your own pronouns i'd love to
be the head of hr but um and i've made
that offer here at the daily wire many
times but whatever company made the
mistake of giving me that job would be
bankrupted by lawsuits in like three
days so as much as i would love it
probably not gonna happen
ten inks says uh i know someone on
riddle and slash adderall is the same
logic as
i learned about gender from talking to
trans people
i suppose people have always been moved
more by stories than by reason
yeah
that's correct but especially when it
comes to as you point out
when it comes to the issue of
pharmaceuticals it's just this people
relying on anecdotes
it's a scourge
people that can't see beyond the
anecdotes well i know someone and they
took it and they were but
yeah that's that's an anecdote that's
one person's experience and that's fine
but you do
you have to expand beyond that and look
at the overall scope of the issue
uh jr roper says depression discussion
are you getting adequate sleep are you
getting enough if any real exercise are
you eating healthy foods let's explore
what you think is healthy by the way
are you saturating your mind in social
media have you taken the time to really
assess yourself how are your
relationships are you limiting your
partner to just one person how is your
financial situation if necessary what do
you plan to do to improve it do you have
a hobby drinking and binging netflix is
not considered a hobby are you
overweight i could go on not all but a
vast majority are not willing to put in
any work to improve their health and
well-being
well yeah they're exactly right and the
thing is
if there's any place for these kinds of
drugs
to treat depression or anxiety or any
problem like that if there's any place
for them
it would not come and should not come
until that until you've gone down that
whole checklist
and you've addressed every single one of
the issues that you're talking about
i mean the idea
that we're giving anyone antidepressants
without first making sure that they're
getting enough sleep that they're
getting exercise that they're eating
well all these things
like that should be the very first thing
that we do
take care of all of those
see how you feel and then come back to
me
that's what the doctors should be saying
if they really cared about treating
people and helping people
here's a checklist of lifestyle of
better you know lifestyle choices that
you could be making
so go fix that make better choices in
your life and then come back and it's no
one is saying that it's a 100 percent
guarantee that if you fix all those
problems you're going to feel better you
might not
but you got to start there that should
be the starting point shouldn't it
just giving people drugs while they're
still making horrible life choices
and and here's the thing you know i
would add another thing to the checklist
which is
are you a mortal human being living in
this veil of tears called life
and that's something that we can all
check yes on that we all are
and this is one of the the most
important salient
facts
that is rarely discussed when it comes
to depression conversation and i've
brought this up before but i don't know
if i'm even articulating it the right
way because it's so fundamental and
basic but it's just something that we
always overlook
but we can't overlook it
and this is why i say that that the the
psychiatry industry
is is starting from some extremely
flawed
presuppositions
okay by ignoring that and i know that
how this sounds when i say it okay
but
you get a way for me to flesh the whole
point out
depression
is actually a perfectly reasonable
response
to the fact of life
because life is very difficult
it's hard
to live it just is
there are so many
things in life that can make people
miserable
and you know for for justifiable reasons
you you don't have to go and look at the
most extreme
tragedies you can imagine just just
think about the people that you know in
your own life and all the things that
they're dealing with
i was just talking about this with my
with my wife that they're for whatever
reason you know as we get older and you
know we get into middle age and um there
are so many people around us in our
lives
who are
just really struggling
their marriages are falling apart and
financial
uh cataclysms and all these kinds of
things you just come along with with
living life
and
we pretend
and here's here's the flawed
presupposition the psychiatry industry
makes
we pretend that being content and happy
is the normal
most natural most effortless thing
right like that should be the baseline
setting
but
but it's not
right and then we say well if you're not
content and happy all the time then
there's something wrong with you with
you in your mind and you need a drug for
it
but that's not the case
how how can anyone look around at life
and at the world and say that well you
know everyone should basically be
content and happy all the time really
have you seen the world have you seen
life
do you realize that you are a mortal
being living here temporarily and then
you're going to die and it's just all
these things
so it's actually the reverse is true
being kind of miserable and sad and down
that is
default setting for a lot of people
being content and happy
is the thing that takes effort and work
which which doesn't mean that that
people shouldn't be happier that we
should leave people in our misery no
it's just that we should start by
realizing that being kind of sad and
miserable is a is a normal state
actually
being happy is better but it takes work
to get there
and you got to be able to you got to put
the work in and you have to know how to
work for it
and that's something that therapists and
counselors should be helping with and
maybe a few of them do
but a great number of them aren't aren't
going to put in that they don't want to
put the effort in themselves
and so they look for the shortcut which
is the drug
well this is the moment in the show
where in years past i may have read you
an ad for harry's razors i would have
said hey you uh millions of listeners i
love harry's go out and buy one
i'm not gonna do that because i don't
love harry's i hate harry's if you don't
know the story harry's used to advertise
on our shows until someone here i don't
know who said that uh boys or boys and
girls or girls this was just an
unspeakable thing to say and it was too
much for our sponsor who pulled their
ads due to values misalignments well
we're not going to promote products that
hate your values so we did the only
thing that made sense we launched our
own razer company jeremy's razors every
jeremy's razors kit comes with a premium
razor two sets of blades shaving cream
and uh aftershave balm as well it's a
beautiful beautiful thing to behold and
over 70 000 kits have shipped already
including to my house because despite
what you may think i actually do use a
razor sometimes so instead of telling
you i'm a big fan of harry's i'm here to
tell you about the thousands of ex
harry's fans who've literally thrown
their razors in the trash and switched
to jeremy's do not go to harrys.com go
to i hate harrys.com and get your
jeremy's razors founder's kit it's a
time to stop giving your money to woke
up corporations that hey you give it to
jeremy instead now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
i hate to end on such a dour note but
something terrible
has happened tragedy has struck
and i don't know how else to put this
so i'm just going to come out and say it
full frontal has been cancelled
now i know what you're thinking
what's full frontal well it's the late
night comedy show hosted by samantha bee
and i know what you're thinking who is
samantha bee
well maybe stop asking questions for a
minute and just listen cnn has the
heartbreaking story it says after seven
seasons full frontal with samantha bee
will not be returning to tbs this fall
the show announced monday on its
official twitter account uh the talk
show has been on the air since february
2016 on tbs home to a host of syndicated
shows including the big bang theory and
friends
they said quote to our loyal fans we
love you you're very special go home and
go home in peace the show's statement
continued during its run full frontal
santa samantha was nominated four times
in the best variety talk series emmy
category one of the show's specials full
frontal with samantha b presents not the
white house correspondents dinner earned
an emmy for outstanding writing for a
variety special in 2017.
asked about the reason for the
cancellation a tbs spokesperson told cnn
quote as we continue to shape our new
programming strategy we've made some
difficult business-based decisions
i'm sorry but i just don't buy it
business-based decision
sounds like code for sexism to me
i mean i can't imagine why else they
would cancel the show especially since
it's been on such a roll recently i mean
just to show you what i mean let's play
a short clip of the uproarious comedic
monologue she delivered about the row
decision a couple of weeks ago just get
ready for some gut-busting comedy folks
listen
medical professionals say that these
prosecutions are often based on faulty
science and disproportionately hurt
low-income women and women of color
which at this point is basically the
slogan for our country and if you think
republicans will stop at abortion itself
bless your heart some red state
legislators in places like idaho are
even prepared to outlaw some of the most
popular forms of birth control you heard
that right outlaw birth control what's
next outlaw condoms
oh wait that's actually a great name for
a condom company when republicans
propose bills that suggest life begins
at fertilization they're making the
argument that just having an iud could
be a form of murder it is not it is a
form of making sure the boyfriend you
had in your early 20s doesn't stay in
your life forever i'll be honest i feel
hopeless i feel rage that every woman in
america has been left to make a plan for
how to take care of themselves in a
country that values a zygote more than
them i feel
like my throat hurts it's probably just
the covet
now was any of that remotely funny
no
was it uncomfortable and embarrassing to
watch
yes
is samantha bee kind of like the
socially unaware dinner guest who keeps
launching into long stories that are
supposed to be funny or interesting but
instead are just boring and the more she
talks the more awkward it gets as
everyone else at the table shoots
glances at each other each praying
silently that she'll stop talking so
they can get the conversation back on
track
yes 100
but is that a good excuse to cancel the
only female late night comedy host
absolutely not
truly there's no telling why exactly
this decision has been made after seven
seasons
some have speculated that they're
canceling the show because it's terrible
and has no audience some have pointed
out that its ratings were so low that
even the wnba felt sorry for it some in
fact have actually speculated that
samantha b was bankrolled by the wnba
because it made the league's ratings
look better by comparison i don't know
if that's true or not there are some
who've said that uh samantha bee's brand
as this scowling humorless wine mom of
late night just didn't resonate with
viewers
some have said that if they wanted to be
yelled at by an ill-tempered middle-aged
blonde woman they just go work the cash
register at a grocery store
some have pointed to the fact that her
show made less money than a child's
overpriced lemonade stand some have said
that tbs could replace its full frontal
revenue just by holding like a yard sale
once a month
some have even claimed that comedy shows
are supposed to be funny
but they say samantha b show is about as
funny as watching someone drown
they've said that there have been
house fires funnier than samantha bee
there are some who've said that that
that the black plague was a hilarious
slapstick farce compared to full front
of what's the man to be some have said
many other things like this and i find
them all offensive
i do not endorse any of those statements
i am simply telling you what other
people have said probably
as for myself i can tell you
that i had faith
a deep abiding faith that samantha bee
would at some point during some episode
managed to tell a funny joke
she tried for seven seasons and failed
but you know what stand-up comedians
always say this is their motto they say
if at first you bomb get back up there
and bomb again
and keep bombing over and over and over
again forever
that's either
stand-up comedians or al qaeda i'm not
sure which one but if you keep going and
keep telling jokes however bad they
might be statistically it just seems
almost certain that eventually you'll
stumble upon a funny one right
samantha bee never got there
because tbs canceled her before she had
a chance
they only gave her six years which is
not nearly long enough
nbc has given seth meyers more time than
that to figure it out and he's still
trying
which means that this is sexism once
again rearing its ugly head and telling
a woman that she isn't funny
which of course is true
it usually is but she could have been
funny
one day
i believed in her
i was watching and rooting for her
well i wasn't watching nobody was but i
was rooting
so i washed my hands of this travesty i
had nothing to do with it this isn't my
fault it isn't samantha bee's fault you
know it's your fault
and tbs is full
for not supporting her and believing in
her
and because of your callous disregard
samantha b
hit the glass ceiling and rather than
breaking through it she splattered
against it like a bug on a windshield
for that reason you
are all canceled
shame on you all how dare you
that'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show in
anticipation of a second quarter of
negative growth the biden administration
redefines recession itself the collapse
of new york city continues the pace and
we explore two very different stories
about racism in america that's today on
the ben shapiro show give it a listen